well you know the Oscar Meyer
Wienermobile has been hot dogging on the
highways across the country for decades
and it's right now in Las Vegas well
Frankly Speaking Laura negretti is here
to give us the hot details on this hot
diggity dog
hot diggity dog that's right yep we are
here in the Oscar Meyer winner mobile
it's about 60 of hot 60 hot dogs in
length here I'm joined by corn dog Clara
who else and another guest oh yes this
is Frank he joins us on all of our
adventures perfect well Clara walk you
know let's drive down Oscar Meyer Memory
Lane here absolutely the Wienermobile
was invented in 1936 so it's 86 years
old uh it was invented by Carl Meyer the
nephew of Oscar Meyer during the Great
Depression as a way to bring joy to a
world that really needed it and so
that's what we continue to strive to do
today at every event we go to in the
Wienermobile definitely you've certainly
accomplished that I know I'm having a
good time my anchors are having a great
time watching us in the Wienermobile so
yeah mission accomplished Miles of
Smiles and now as far as the rest of
this week here you're here still Sunday
what can people expect why should they
come on out oh my goodness we're going
to be having Buns of fun relishing the
moment come get your picture with the
Wienermobile uh and make some memories
that'll last forever you know people
bring their families to this their their
kids their grandkids
um ages 8 to 80. love the Wienermobile
so come join us you can see the inside
of the Wienermobile get one of our
iconic weenie whistles and uh yeah enjoy
the the wonderful day with us yeah
wonderful day riding a you get to jump a
shot Bun over there Relish in the moment
catching up with you guys no it sounds
like a great time here and you've got
your own little first memory here
because you're from you're from Oregon
and then you saw it here and it kind of
kind of Full Circle for you too right
absolutely yes it's so fantastic to be
back here in the west the West is where
I grew up seeing the Wienermobile always
dreamed of driving this thing and and
now I get to explore my my very own you
know Turf in the Wienermobile definitely
well thank you so much again it's going
to be here through Sunday we've got that
full list of events for you on our
website 8newsnow.com for now live in the
winter by the Lauren Grady 8 News Now
there you go I was waiting for the
whistle they're just an ambassador of
fun you know they've made a lot of
different mobiles they even have a
weenie Bago
an RV I'll fit it out right okay not
lying all right okay okay all right
Heather